The joe rogan experience,
but I know that it's,
you know,
the,
especially the border towns,
they're incredibly dangerous.
I mean it's just people
going down left and right.
Getting headless and fucking body pack.
It was safe before safe.
It's interesting when a culture like
drastically changes over a fairly short
period of time.
I used to go to Mexico and we just go
to the spring break thing on TV in like
the late nineties you know,
maybe like two,
maybe even the early two
thousands it was like no big deal.
Yeah,
it was for fear factor.
The gride.
Yeah.
We used to get our pump on that was sweet
and taught me how to shave my chest.
I believe all of this totally.
Yeah.
Were dance partners.
We're going to be the first gay
couple on dancing with the stars.
We're going to come on.
There we go.
He's going to help me
for how long?
For how long?
Like an hour or I could watch
that longer than the head cutting.
What'd you get your watch?
Two guys fuck.
Easier than it head coming.
I find that hard to believe why you
mean in real life or on the Internet?
I've never even watched
it on the Internet.
Pull it up for Brian.
So Brian,
the only way this is gonna work
is take the monitor and um,
don't,
don't stream the show.
And then on that screen over there,
you need to show two guys
fucking just for Amy.
So well it won't ever show you.
You can do that,
right?
I want it to be
mixed master flesh to flesh.
I actually invented that name.
The guy's name was flashed.
Mixed master slash master flesh
by accident.
Yeah.
Right.
It just fucks.
Everybody shows up and flings.
Dick.
My name is cheese cream.
Can I get a rap name?
Well,
my rap name be.
I always felt like if we're
going to have a nickname,
you can't really nicknamed
herself knowing his
nickname
is fuck
this here folks
made your own nickname up.
It means you have no friends.
That's the only thing it means.
It doesn't make any sense.
Other than that,
you're a crazy person.
Crazy person.
Fighters.
It's hilarious.
Fighters come up with some of the silliest
nicknames to stick with it and it's
there forever.
Guys Change.
Like Rory Macdonald,
he used to call himself the water boy,
and then he changed his to Aries.
God of war.
Yeah.
It's kind of interesting where
you're allowed to change your name,
change
waterboy but now I feel
more like the god of war.
Oh,
okay.
Just do whatever you want.
I guess just the world is yours.
So what the God of war in
relation to like Mexico crumbling.
I'm reading this,
I'm listening rather to this podcast
that explains what the fuck is wrong with
the Middle East.
And W one of the reasons why the Middle
East is so backwards and fucked up.
His Gingiss con king,
his car rolled two
there in 1200 something.
It wasn't gangs.
It was actually a sons.
So he was already dead
and crushed Baghdad.
Killing everybody
and I million people is that people
fucking that gay guys fucking it's too.
You know what?
Are they fucking right there?
Because he just,
he pulled up to elderly fat guys fucking,
and I'm not.
No.
You know what,
I maybe you're right.
Maybe I assumed it was going to be like,
take it away.
But like I said,
there's going to be right.
That's not cool.
We're not going to get an honest reaction.
As long as she's seen it.
Now we can say that we were
the first person to show it to.
Oh,
she's looking right at it right now.
You know what?
It doesn't bother me.
She was looking right at it.
Just Scott.
Okay.
I honestly don't feel
bummed out about it a way.
We're good.
We'll get to the sex.
No,
no,
no.
That's enough.
It's not about me.
It's honestly not bothered.
They're blowing each other like two
gentlemen who measure their mouth.
Fucking I call him.
I'll fucking,
yeah.
I don't know.
You know what?
I didn't see them penetrating each other.
That might've been a different vibe.
I didn't mind the 69.
Yeah.
We need to get,
you know,
you've got to prove that you see the
actual fucking I seen him right there,
clearly,
huh?
Yeah.
I uh,
I thought it was going to bum me out,
but yeah.
Fuck him.
Okay.
There you go.
Great.
Well,
thank you guys.
We got to do this together.
You're welcome.
So anyway,
the cons rolled.
The Mongols rolled through
Baghdad and the 1200
yeah.